no here you go it wasn't Mexican bingo
welcome to and that's a typical punch
song interim no it wasn't a Mexican guy
welcome to another episode of punch
drunk sports I got an interesting crew
today we got no Sammy we got no nanny
but we do have the great chef dan is
from Danish Antonio podcast hooray and
my good friend drum first time on the
show everybody I'm excited to be here
Johnny's here Aaron's here Aaron was
just telling us is still the divorce is
still is it final yet it's it's not
happening that's oh I keep saying this
oh yeah okay I get well I guess that's
what she said anyway but maybe maybe
it's gonna be a surprise to you and the
place is bustling today bustling
bustling I saw Bill Cosby in the lobby
right yeah they let him out one day
furlough to do a video here came in here
to shoot something with Erica yeah
they're doing the Bill and Eric show no
theme song they do it they we do those
all right thank you guys do alive right
how unprofessional of me yeah I was
listening to your new episode this
weekend it seemed like you had technical
problems with it this vehicle yeah hello
yeah I forgot a speaker is the technical
problems oh that's what about yeah it
happens I love your podcast oh let's do
it all time thank you
let's just play it over this and then we
can't and I'll leave you can use your
Dino sponsors if you want uh yeah bet
TSI everybody why not do bet DSi - you
know Neal have you made money on it on
the on what I'm debt by Diaz I I'm using
it yeah yeah I'm a multimillionaire now
is that [ __ ] good that's great yeah
if you use our promo code you're
guaranteed to win what is that promo
code it's deal 101 but don't use that
one use a code punch-drunk yeah check
get you 25 free bucks to gamble with and
all of our predictions are usually very
wrong each so if you use either one of
those you're supporting my family so
there you go you can't lose you
literally cannot lose you can't lose
yeah baby barb can't lose he's going to
college what is he what
offshore gaming site it's actually great
a great site all the all the you know
it's all guaranteed they've been around
like 20 years and yeah and they'll
double up to 500 bucks whatever you put
in really yeah I tried to get FanDuel
the for the wilder fight oh don't do
that yeah we wouldn't let me do it I
wish I knew I would've told you this
I'll give you 25 free bucks and whatever
you put in you could literally double oh
that's the so cuz that wilder fight was
money in the bank right yeah no well I
they had like they had like a online I
saw it was like plus twenty two hundred
first round knockout and I'm like I'll
put something on that yeah yeah sure and
then I was even if it's ten bucks oh
yeah yeah yeah and it wouldn't let me do
it cuz I wasn't in Jersey which is
[ __ ] [ __ ] see that's you could be
anywhere in the world use bet - yeah the
American ones oh it's only legal because
it's legal in Jersey I guess yeah boxing
Gene Wilder G yeah gene Wilder is boxing
hell of a lot that guy comin straight
you get that knockout up he comes out as
Willy Wonka yeah comes out as Willy
Wonka you punch them hot enough his hat
comes off and see that role coming yeah
the UH I think Walter could be
heavyweight champ who is heavyweight
champ oh but he has on that unified oh
yeah I don't know it's that'll be a good
fight it's it's like the three-way a
three-way battle between like Joshua and
in fury is like yeah it's just so all
over the place because they all have
their like flaws like you know like
Wilders not really it's yeah they all
have different match oh yeah kind of
fury is like a good you know he's a good
mix of brute strength and you know all
that [ __ ] but he's just he's white I
think Joshua was probably the best of
them all and welfare roids
so it's like how do you say that look at
what that's this thing that's that's why
he's not fighting as he oh because he
does want to be tested yeah that's what
and he doesn't want to fight over ducks
people he doesn't want to fight in
America he only wants to fight in where
the [ __ ] you yeah England where is there
a guy named like boner he is a he's a
flexing on Instagram right now okay it's
so funny there was a really funny video
at like so his whole thing is like he's
about billions as
that's this whole thing I'm about
billions I make all this money Yeti at
it and there's a video that surfaced to
him sitting in coach and someone's like
oh you got that she was bald
yeah yeah he just got he just go I'm
comfortable though that's how you make
the money though you save it on the
flight yeah yeah yeah that much but he's
wearing like anything else and he's in
in the video he's wearing like you know
allegedly like a million dollars worth
of jewelry sure she traded it in for
some tickets yeah and he's sitting in
like he's sitting in like row 25 I heard
he flies with boxing gloves you can't
even put on his own seat belt boy that's
cuz he's flying spirit it's flying
spirit he didn't want to pay the extra
no shirt no shirt just boxing shorts
[Laughter]
boxing gloves and his belt and he's got
a nametag stuck to his just bare chest
are you looking for that video yeah I
can't find it Adrian Adrian Broner coach
coach and it comes out he changed
trainers Oh flying coach flies coach and
that's him and his trainer flying in a
very tall oh it's true it's true Vontae
uh what David David no that's who calls
about yeah he's great
javante that person's like they they're
like it's a bold move say he punches you
know I mean they're in the same light
they train in the same gym right human
they got beef Javonte davis is uh he's a
badass he Javonte davis is like under
Floyds can't like like Broner or wishes
he was then he was a boy was it kind of
kinda like he was like his little
brother but they kind of had beef like
brahma he thought he tried to do the
philly shell and yeah well he just
wanted to emulate mayweather but he
didn't put in the work to do so i don't
think you beat the women that we did
with them then I'm cool with them then
you're gonna emulate mayweather yeah you
gotta teach these chicks lessons the
only thing you got was a [ __ ] talking
and that was it you got to make sure you
get that one thing that we know you're a
punch drunk is that when women get be
it's better it's wrong but they never
really say with
deserve it right guys guys guys and that
was brought to you by Betty si oh he's
the king of it he's the king of it and
what is going on here today why is it so
jammed up in here parking lots full
there's like 30 people out there Flattr
of convention bro Cosby's here
no marcel Arguello is doing a shoot
upstairs oh okay that's right there's so
many people our Seles Wiley Marcellus
Wiley yeah dude I just threw his tripod
off the overpass and pay old a guy
[ __ ] headshots it's like a javelin
like a javelin have gone wrong he's
stolen will who stole that tripod and
then was so pissed off they threw it off
of an overpass and this isn't really the
right tripod that I stole I'm just gonna
kill somebody that's it that's some
Ripley's Believe It or Not [ __ ] there
you remember that yeah this looks a
little Photoshop to me that's how much
that would scare the magazine oh yeah I
think I think that would be why you get
to keep the tribe hey free tripod that's
a pretty sweet deal you're like the bad
news is it's in my body yeah now I'm
part of a tripod well once it comes out
I can use it yeah it's from Sacramento
police [ __ ] tripod javelin off Jesus
why did they catch the person that did
it yeah let's just say did they catch
the guy that did it says that there's no
way that's a woman why cuz she that's
not a woman throw it well that's one and
what for one you throw that tripod right
a woman would commit what why not I
don't think so I'd be willing to bet
money on bat dsi that that was a man and
not a woman's crime well yeah unless
that's like her disgruntled like
relationship like her accent she got the
really target one car that yeah
yeah the suspect a 32 year old transient
currently residing in Sacramento was
transported to South Sacramento it
doesn't save it's me now he has a home
for a long time so he sure it wasn't
Macaulay Culkin why do you say that
Aaron did you not see the good son oh
yeah that's a good point
why I did not see the good son a good
son pull he throws like a dummy off of
an overpass yeah for fun a child
horrified Oh like in a like the know bam
margera [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah I've
delivered goods to Macaulay Culkin's
home is that true yes how's he doing
he's a guy ah he was all right we're
likes to wear pajamas
yeah match today no micro machines on
the ground fortunate okay no Michael
Jackson wasn't heated he was all right I
kind of wouldn't regular guys you
deliver to him there I salute heroin
groceries Oh nicely yeah and then one
time Mila Kunis came to the door she was
the better tipper the two I bet she has
more money yeah how easy is she on the
eyes live in person she has to be a
smoke show yeah we had sex couple that's
you wait which one you in Balkan all of
them all right yeah that's a decent tip
you can see the video I made with them
it's called the home a bone I audition
for that actually yeah you you are going
out to be a Daniel Stern yeah yeah yeah
wait he looks that he looks like the
same kid in [ __ ] home alone it is no
no but I'm saying like the same
character yeah it's like probably he's a
real evil yet spin-off movie where he
Kevin when you spin off the highway
where it starts you know that being left
alone for weeks amazing develops a meth
problem and [ __ ] loses his marbles
Chuck and [ __ ] tripods off of the
interstate and what yes day is rough if
home alone wasn't slapstick it would be
very violent think of all the shade I'd
burn those guys and but uh Mick Foley
the wrestler when a lot of people were
saying wrestling was too violent on head
injuries he was like we'll look at a
movie like home alone and he like looked
like how many concussions it would cause
there's paint cans to the head he's like
if kids can watch that then why can't
they watch pro wrestling did an
interesting argument yeah and the other
point I missed those days the Hartwick
when they had like the hardcore matches
and [ __ ] like now it's all yeah now
they're not taking chair shots to the
head like they were in the 90s yeah just
cuz chris benoit come on guys come on
guys one guy goes crazy yeah dies from
jumping off of a [ __ ] from from doing
a diving headbutt year after year who
would have thought that move would lead
to head trauma not me yeah definitely
not me that sucks if you get CTE from us
you're not even doing a sport yeah
you're acting yeah it's like hey I was
in a play but now I have CTE yeah right
they have a Hall of Fame that people
take really seriously it should be a CTE
Hall of Fame should be one yeah I mean a
lot of great players that had CTE boxers
and they go I didn't go Jake probably
could be certain could be a factor you
would think they said that uh what's his
name Aaron Hernandez when they look at
yeah definitely they said that he had
the highest level of CTE that they've
seen in all the NFL brains they've
looked at which is really only about a
dozen there's not they haven't looked at
a zillion of them some of them that
killed themselves like shot themselves
in the chest so you could study their
brain yeah but that's how they were
conscious enough to be like I want to
save my brain for science I'm in so much
pain to end it all but yeah well really
like that was in a weird way kind of
like a heroic movie if you're gonna kill
yourself because at that point in time
not a lot of brains have been studied by
the NFL shot himself in the heart
specifically for that reason yeah
there was a guy for the bitter Steelers
yeah there was another person the same
oh the guy from the from concussion from
the show I mean the movie concussion
Will Smith's the doctor looks at them
alright yeah yeah yeah yeah hey guys
everything now you did Jeannie
I can't even suspend disbelief to see
him as a genie because he looks so much
they're just looks like blue Will Smith
well it's hard to you could
please reach movie star status where
it's yeah well you look at him you're
like like every Tom Cruise movie it's
Tom Cruise you're not [ __ ] you know
yeah Bill Clinton you're clearly Tom
Curren to the role yeah yeah yeah yeah
and Will Smith is probably the king of
that that Aladdin looks like made-for-tv
movie I don't think it's gonna be good
looks no I think it looks like a [ __ ]
daytime are like ruff who did this
lifetime it'll do well Guy Ritchie
directed that's how I met Guy Ritchie
directed that yeah really
yep that's not weird movie announcing
Rogen really oh wow I'm Seth Rogen Seth
Rogen's night nighttime show the Seth
Rogen experience you know who used to
call Seth Rogen Seth Rogen was the great
Tommy Morris of The Comedy Store
oh yeah that's a erosion okay why would
see white why did his name come out of
who knows was he coming up four spots
probably ya know I forget I think he was
saying that he didn't think he was funny
or something I don't know what the [ __ ]
it was yeah it was important that
doesn't mean much whatever it was it was
important information all right he's in
like [ __ ] Aruba or some [ __ ] he wasn't
uh South America but I think he's back
the OS was he like on the runner he was
on vacation at both I think he's trying
to find a witch doctor to bring Mitzi
shore back to life
yeah so far he hasn't done it he had to
go to South America he may be going to
Haiti next we'll see yeah Wow he's
either laughs he still does that I bet
he meets people in these foreign
countries and just about his former job
no like
Wow Wow that's what she said why we to
put you in the kitchen what if he goes
down there and starts like the comedy
store of South America I wouldn't be
shot and and it's fly though it would
not be for would it be he's working
there but what if he was though we're
smelling car one of the worst smelling
cars I ever parked Oh Tom Morris because
you had to park it it was that that
Harry which which car which is black
whatever the [ __ ] it was the that little
Honda the old Toyota dude is it smelled
like a wet dog in there cuz that mullet
its mullet horrible I'd say the worst
smelling car in the Comedy Store was
always was a I say Roddy Piper really or
it's a tie between him and a murder what
car I could see that Ryan Marissa's car
stinks well like dog what yet cuz he had
a dog that he would always take out and
he was always like going to like rock
festivals for like three days and not
showering and going straight to the
store yeah what a Piper Drive I remember
his car it was like an old school
Mercedes convertible I do remember that
yep yep yep
yeah what is uh just bad just a bad you
know it smelled it just smelled like a
wrestler like a locker room it's like a
locker room yeah it just like didn't
smell good did he have like wrestlers in
the back seat there was no back seat is
this there was no word for this smelled
again I was just like it live it in the
two-seater yeah and plus his son I think
it's if his son was driving that car too
is someone's like a UFC fighter spy
still is
oh I'm talking [ __ ] then when he died he
was I think if someone's like 20 and he
was telling me about he was training
them in May I don't know whatever I mean
not UFC fighter but that's how I met mmm
better but he had like had like three
like amateur fights already or some
loser hyper trained before like there
really wasn't me he looked really yeah
he's a real fight like he like knew some
real [ __ ] he's a nice guy I only met him
a few times I didn't see him up there a
lot I was I used to like rewatch a lot
of those old UFC's back when like you
you just what they wore like full
outfits when they fought and [ __ ] back
wasn't interesting the black guy who had
one box one box ago up that was Thomas I
think I think they should bring I think
I should be on the disadvantaged they
should bring back that like like those
like divisions like like sex one eye
patch for new era like
should make them they should have a
division where they were like hoodies
and baggy pants like that would be
[ __ ] the street fighting yeah like a
[ __ ] ah dad dad you know that'd be a
test of endurance to see like MMA rules
though
no it's same same thing but they're just
wearing like clothes like you know like
bar fight division that's a big
difference if you train jiu-jitsu if you
use the gear yogi yes you can like choke
guys out with like hardly the fabric
yeah there's also that's why they that's
why they and you can grab like the
people get like windy tournaments like
people get choked out with their own
shirt yeah yeah oh okay so I get you
from behind and get that around and you
can get a good grip on a shirt and
purses I like slippery head neck that ya
know sweatin and oiled up that's why I
always grapple with a scarf and [ __ ]
with scars you can do a lot of different
moves yeah just seen this clothes right
necktie have you guys seen that they're
doing the in Florida at the Florida
State Fair they're doing their first
bare-knuckle boxing a chance of course
if it was law Paulie Molly Holly Molly
Gianni is boxing some dudes this is he
Pauly Shore know they're really selling
this fight though they really are Tim
Lobo yeah Conor McGregor yeah it's a guy
that everyone slaps in the face
wait oh that's it that's this whole
thing is getting like well like huh be
that you jumped a member wearing could
be jumped out of the thing and went
after somebody that's who he was going
after really when Connor through the
dahle through the bus because Habib
slapped this guy in the face yeah before
the before his fight and now not she's
going for revenge for that training
video that leaked I like his hat
he's spit on them too he saw a piece of
it that looks fake though because Lobo
just you like me like a half step you
didn't really make a full effort to get
there yeah I think I want to watch this
though what is this
bare-knuckle dude though it's June 22nd
I would I want to go to it they're
faithful they're so mangle it's hard to
watch oh you mean during the fight yeah
and teeth and [ __ ] like it's [ __ ] bad
well I mean I wouldn't mind watching
Polly mother Johnny lose some teeth me
too
he's like I'm so tired I just got [ __ ]
over by Connor in those guys they were
only they were all the footage and they
only released him get knocked down of
course they're trying to sell the fight
but they had an agreement not to release
any footage and he came in and trained
with the guy did him a favor
oh I'm sure I bet they put money in his
pocket he didn't just show up not he
didn't have to pull him on though she
doesn't have to go train with [ __ ]
Conor McGregor help him get prepared for
hey man why'd he do it cuz they paid him
a lot but they but they agreed you can
see how much they breathe not really
stuff I bet I bet that wasn't a [ __ ]
I mean think about thousand dollar day
for him I don't know if you had an
agreement not really footage of
something like you know an actress I
mean somebody released it right before
you can read come out with special you'd
be pissed same thing happened to me I
was [ __ ] this lady we were filming it
just to like have it and I was like this
isn't gonna be released right she
released it I was just trying out new
stuff yeah that wasn't my a-game and she
knocked you down like that it would be
like if she released the worst part of
your set but he's like a shitty person
like I thought you thought you're like
[ __ ] her from behind then you fall
down and pull a hamstring yeah oh god
yeah call my mommy I'm back
you got your inhaler sit in the corner
feeding off yeah that's my move
especially if I'm going down on ya you
always take the hit of the inhaler yeah
yeah I was jammed in the clam and give
it a push I I liked him as a boxer I
mean cuz he didn't have a lot of power
Paulie Malignaggi and he would get beat
up a lot and who did he was I kept
trying he was that De La Hoya he was his
whole thing is like he had the toughest
schedule that's his whole thing but he
was like the guy you'd to beat up so
that you can fight the champ yeah like
he stunted people here and there he
reminded me of like a poor man's Arturo
Gatti like you like that area I don't
know poor weight you know you put him
above a Toro Gaddy no no hello oh he's
the poor man
yeah yeah like he'd beat Zab Judah
Nero's at the end it's up to his career
chef Judah came into the comedy store
one night when I was working there
really
on the quote-unquote urban night because
on Tuesdays I punched him in the face
he's a coda really how'd that go I
didn't punch him buddy Wow Gael Cotto he
had some good bling that's eight that's
all another there used to be a guy who'd
come in every Tuesday went by the name
Charlie Dee and he would come in the
back door
he was like fifty to sixty years old any
big black guy he'd always be like Oh
Charlie Dee's hit what's up man like it
would announce his presence in third
person ya comic no just like a guy was
it the black dude with the like hump on
his neck
I can't remember but then he would
always be like there's a boxing match
coming up you'll see me in the ring and
I was like this guy's so full of [ __ ]
and then I watched the box it was on HBO
and he was in the [ __ ] ring he's like
fighting you know he's like boys with
Don King oh he's just like a promoter
without God okay like a part of them in
every [ __ ] week come in the back door
and they'd yell at me that people come
in the back door wait was it so y'all
had rules back then when you were
working because like when I when I first
I working at the story was like there
were no Rudy didn't really trip on us
well it was it was their show so they
would they would yell at me because they
had their own security guard who sat at
the main room door yeah
and so he he would say he was an ex-con
because his brother worked there and I
was like hey man where'd your brother
come from and so he's been in prison for
like a long time I was like okay he was
a huge [ __ ] guy he was built like
Suge Knight just like a big like a disk
brick [ __ ] he once like hit me on
the chest as like a joke and it like
nailed me back into the wall like and I
was like whoa man he's oh sorry man like
hey Fletcher crack one of my ribs just
by squeezing mean he wouldn't stop
squeezing like he had me up in the air
really yeah yeah damn it god damn it
then I text him next day yeah I think
you cracked one of my ribs and he just
texts me back [ __ ] oh and then and so
what did he did you go to the doctor
yeah and it was like one firm bottom one
was you had a little crack at it and
there's nothing you can do for it you
should attack I couldn't laugh I
couldn't [ __ ] I couldn't sleep well so
like sternum - oh wow
you should have tap dude I saw I was I
was tapping like a [ __ ] this guy
we really wanted to but one saw tape
Fletcher and like five of his buddies a
lot of them were smaller dudes there a
tall MMA guys and they were like really
manhandling a real Skakel at the calm
that's a game he loves to be like like
submitting kata Louise counter girl and
they're all you know he's like you wish
you could wear a Johnny belani sweater
brother you know he always has like
brags about what designer and tato come
up and just be like yeah like that coat
give it to me come on no I'm not [ __ ]
around give it to me I'm gonna take it
yeah don't stretch it out baby and then
like five minutes later you see Tate
walking around wearing it anyone give it
back to him like all night these guys
were like what size they were built like
he said what size shoe or you wear it
guys are all built like your eye a favor
they were like five six but like ripped
and they were just all like taking turns
like ninjas all around him all the time
for years like yeah every time he sees
me child yeah but he saw like all these
like all his buddies were there and he's
like hey what's he gonna do anything I
know that's [ __ ] you [ __ ] at their
mercy that's funny
speaking of tape Fletcher guys you go to
came in coffee company go to caveman
coffee calm use the code punch drunk
Annette gets you I think 20% off 15% off
something like that but get the nitros
by the way completely out of nitros week
one refrigerator full of them at all
things comedy sent a to pix remedies
like a rad that looks great in there
not anymore completely gone the port
Keith Jardine one of the band Keith
Jardine one of the best actors he was in
bird box they're both in all kinds of
those beards they really get work yeah
if you're like a big guy that looks like
somebody that you would be a bad guy
they must go out for a lot of the same
roles I think that they do wonder if it
affects their friendship and working
relationship they have to fight for it
they Photoshop his head and this picture
has some reason I have no idea larious
so go to Kimmie coffee use a code punch
up and what I recommend is they got T's
they got everything they got all that
fancy butter you can put in coffee
they got maybe who knows but they have
coffee enemas because I've been into
those lately have you
yeah I've been into a - the coffee part
okay maybe not mine's more like a dildo
enema Oh Oh someone's standing behind
shaking it
yeah and it's a car I guess there's a
cardboard cutout take my chance good
that's scary man waking up to like tape
Fletcher just stated your bed look good
for home security but they should
probably put some color on it so it
looks like that thing they have in the
7-eleven windows just like a but yeah
yeah yeah yeah imagine though if you
just like wake up in the middle of the
night and like take Fletcher's just at
the end of your bed looking at you oh
you don't know anybody at the end of
your bed really scary child regardless
of who it is like who the [ __ ] what are
you doing didn't the cage wake up to a
naked person
uh yes everybody else did dude there's
another celebrity that someone was like
taking a shower in their house or
something when I got home Wow oh that
was uh [ __ ] who was that once it was
like Keanu Reeves or that sounds right
that sounds right just like hey you mind
getting out of the shower yeah come on
your showers running you're like god
damn dude but didn't but but it some
didn't like Robert Downey jr. like break
into someone's house and like fall
asleep yeah yeah kid's room that'd be
cool you're like Iron Man guys he came
to see was a free Iron Man it was like
it was like never before
hey it's the guy from back to school
yeah weren't you in the brat pack now
he's sleeping in my son's bed I heard he
lived there for he just let him stay he
said that he got pulled over doing like
95 in his convertible Porsche totally
naked with like five thousand dollars
worth of cocaine and the front seat and
a gun Wow where the where where is
clothes I don't know totally naked
driving would wouldn't be good I don't
think now what I mean he'd be a worried
your seat would have [ __ ] yeah I'm
gonna pee a little bit man say you have
to get out of the car
yeah and if it's a stick shift like a
Porsche you know Target jerk off and do
it you know just like yeah we'll be even
doing yeah now I'm just earring with my
leg what do you get for that did he get
pulled over he went to jail
like jail for a long [ __ ] time really
yeah I think he was in for look how long
he was in jail Robert Downey jr. well
this is the thing on the drugs charge he
broke into his neighbor's home and
passed out in their bedroom
Oh his neighbor's house do you think it
was his house this was a classic
misunderstanding oh this was a 96 I
would assume so yeah he was 30 you
wanted the time that happened to my
friend of mine but good friend Mindy she
got home Mindy Kaling's beauty Kalin's
yeah you don't - she lives on the fourth
floor and get Tom you know Mindy I don't
know her but you know I'm talking about
you she oh she live in her building yeah
used to yeah but she so she lives on a
fourth floor and she gets home and gets
him bad like late at night like 2:00
a.m.
gets him bad and feels on leg and she's
like what - like a man's leg turns the
light on she's like who the [ __ ] are you
get the [ __ ] out here and he's like all
drunk he's like I live here she's like
you don't [ __ ] leave and then she
looks in the hallway like all of his
[ __ ] was in the hallway he was just
peeling his clothes off and then crawled
in her bed how the [ __ ] did he get in
she lives in like apartment like 410 and
he lives in 310 oh so he thought that
yeah yes yes knock the door no yeah the
key he had a key under her mat and so
did he apparently so it's like a weird
coincidence that he walks up in [ __ ]
she says like called me and I called the
Cata call the cops and [ __ ] it was crazy
that's how my parents met actually they
just stayed together after it's like
you're already here yeah yeah yeah we
might as well have a child yeah so then
yeah I had three kids you Jewish by
chance yeah there was and there was only
one yeah I was just a same house and
they're like [ __ ] it let's just live
together
yeah let's cohabitate [ __ ] who cares
have anybody I know Johnny hasn't we
talked about it earlier today have
either of you two seen at Muhammad Ali
documentary no phenomenal what does it
call Game of Thrones
what's my name I I just like it's I feel
wow how many new stories that I have
about I thought the same thing I thought
the exact same thing I literally cried
at the end of the second one it only
made me cry how many episodes two each
one is 90 minutes does it deal with any
of the Michael Jackson
was there any crossover none yeah a lot
of the same kids they [ __ ] touched
their it being interviewed for some
reason yeah it was incredible they
literally go through every single fight
they don't maybe on some of them they
don't you know show much but all of his
whole record every single thing he was
so [ __ ] funny there's so many
interviews I've never seen yeah so much
footage I've never seen and it really
really really gets into his civil rights
activism and his like global activism
mmm from the jump from the jump the
whole Vietnam thing which he knew a lot
about but there's so much other [ __ ]
that I didn't know about he was so
[ __ ] funny made me laugh a shitload
what a charisma there's been a guy and a
lot of people now heard pretty much
ripping him off Conor McGregor's know
everybody always has been and he he was
talking about when maybe it was Ken
Norton or it was who maybe Frazier what
wouldn't fight for the title they had
the title but I just kind of sat on it
and they fought twice in two years and
Ali's like when I had the title I fought
12 times 12 fights the heavyweight
fights in two years and that was early
in his career
exactly and he's like calling everybody
out in you know LA he was such a big
payday he was the only payday
he was the first million dollar fight he
was the first five million dollar fight
he was the first ten million dollar
fights that Sonny Liston he was calling
an Uncle Tom know wasn't Sonny Liston
region it wasn't Frazier it was another
guy the first guy that okay that's funny
that's what the title of it came from
Frazier he called gorilla gorilla Sonny
Liston it was who Sonny Liston was who
he called it Uncle Tom cuz I think it
probably like hurt Sonny Liston's feel
it was a guy that might have been Sonny
Liston no it was Frazier
it was Frazier I'm pretty positive are
you sure if I did I just did I just did
a show about it it was fraser-smith
fraser-smith because because no because
Frazier that's why Frazier didn't he
didn't feel sorry for what like Floyd
Patterson Floyd Patterson but he but he
did he did because people because that's
why Frazier would like wasn't apology
about like his whole you know him having
Parkinson's a [ __ ]
Frazier kind of got because he simply
didn't be with him yeah got loopy
towards the end to that's where oh yeah
they all that whole generation did so we
gonna see tes but he was it matters
Foreman because that's why the title of
the film came from because he was the
first person to call Muhammad Ali also
called Ernie taught him yeh called him
cash and then the whole fight when he's
hitting them you could see him he must
have said at seventy five my name what's
my name
even after each round he's like I'm
going to punish you if he said is if he
just said Muhammad Ali what do you have
taken a day just shake hands thanks for
watching us fight everybody
NPR says he called several of his
opponents yeah yeah yeah yeah including
Joe Frazier did but yeah it had last and
like it made because that was really
insulting back then - because that's
what made the Africans like hate him so
much when he went over to you know when
they fought in and yeah he fought over
Africa yeah George Foreman in Kenya was
I know how Jack was Foreman in his prime
he's wearing those overalls with no [ __ ]
he's [ __ ] people ah they show a lot of
his fights to name is doc he's a beast
Kinshasa they had a there's a
documentary about that maybe rumble in
the jungle it's called I think Netflix
that's what it is a rumble that's where
they talk about they were so there was
like a handful maybe like 30 people they
were like the shittiest people in town
like pickpockets and [ __ ] hood
hoodlums and [ __ ] and they invited them
to the arena like a couple days before
the fight and executed every one of them
because they were worried about being
like globally humiliated by these they
always do that when the Olympics always
do that they round up kind of the
riffraff and try to try to get him out
of time yeah here's a buddy here's a bus
ticket to [ __ ] zero yeah we're gonna
clean up the city in 2028 but then they
get all the hook yeah okay they bring in
the flood the city with hookers those
Olympians are just [ __ ] each other
hardcore I bet two have a lot of STDs
going around and only baby a flood
billing
village with condoms but they're just
like that hard pound you know it
apparently brings around a ton of
hookers is golf event they like the
whole a buddy who's a pro golfer he lost
his card this year unfortunately but
he's told me kind of some tournaments
you go in the lobby and it's just every
hooker yeah because I think the number
one people that fought cookers is like
middle or Oprah AIDS white dudes with
money yeah I mean you know people just
thought when golfers are like they're a
lot like their schedules like a road
comic like they're always gone always
gone yes so it's like in you know some
and they're nights are free and some of
them have you know they have families
but they got to get up earlier nights
are free ya know I kind of walked around
some of those events and I'll listen to
players and some of them are like like
talking super like gambling [ __ ] like
it's kind of crazy
breaking news right breaking news I
don't have a dhama concerted the [ __ ]
books oh that's cool cuz they just got
rid of what's this that's why I got rid
of McCoy we need to get McCoy where he's
playing for the Milwaukee Bucks
yeah yeah honest and in dama contempo in
in dominant he's you I he didn't have
that great of a year did he he towards
the Andy dead yeah he's just he's still
dirty he's Jerry I'm gonna worry about
him and the division is knowing the old
your Falcons guys yeah
the old head stomp y'all nuts Tom
Panthers yeah yeah he had good nuts top
on I think who teased uh Aaron Rodgers I
think he stomped on his nuts yeah or is
left on his Lou how old sue now probably
30 33 30 or maybe 31
how many years did he wonder what he got
already 2 and 135 days how much we'll
see in paid I don't know it just came
over it looks like like 15 minutes ago
so I don't know if I like so one year
deal so I think it's okay another one
years 7 million or some [ __ ]
just get that money man yeah times one
your deals when you're older are better
than that long-term deal I get
understand people might like
security and all that there you go one
season ten million ten million yes yeah
that's a guess by this guy but he said
it should look like a good payday one
year Tim what do you think McCoy's are
gonna go you think he's still good
enough to play or they they let him go
do they let him go because I think he
wanted more money and a long-term deal
yeah and this they were like hey and
they started negotiating with sue says
her statement and then they're like oh
okay yeah we could save a shitload of
money because he will draft a tackle
next year or what have you he was good
in the like when they had the Hard
Knocks I was like what three years ago
like I remember him that was a good
season for McCoy yeah uh-huh
the Panthers are on this season of a
month okay so yeah that's a call Oh
All or Nothing yeah that's way better
than the HBO and by the way why it is
have you seen it the Cardinals I like it
better I think I went Cardinals and Rams
I think we're the to write like a better
than HBO yeah I think HBO has an angle
and I think that one has more depth to
it
it's the whole season you watch the
whole season yeah it's the whole season
and you get to know a lot more of the
players other than just like the seven
main ones oh yeah that's why I watch me
I want is formulaic to me I think well I
think HBO one is better because it's
like happening live and it's like it's
like you watch their game and you're
like oh he bout to get cussed out oh
he's gonna get cut like following their
story it makes you want to watch the
preseason game problem with though I
think shows like that is they start off
pretty genuine and then they become
parodies of themselves
yeah the coach is like omen emulate this
other coach I saw and it just becomes
kind of stupid there's always that one
rookie you're rooting for to make the
team one who does and then you get to
know the couple that you know the ring
never makes it know where I'm gonna be
in five they get picked up somewhere the
coaches telling them hey man we thought
you were great maybe we'll we're gonna
release you today and then he and then
he makes us special teams tackle in week
16 yeah yeah that's the guy a touchdown
in the last preseason game you know
maybe I think they should show way more
[ __ ] more shy horses and more like the
guy [ __ ] his girlfriend yeah I got it
yeah I want to I get the relationship
and there's but I want to see the [ __ ]
prove it yeah
prove that you've I don't believe you
guys are really I don't believe the
earth is round for one day to be funny
like to admit he gets cut and he goes it
tells his girlfriend she's like I'm
gonna be releasing you too or a guy's
just already in the room yeah guy that
did make the team that was hammer in her
shut yeah this is my I'm staying in town
he's that you could leave I'm gonna stay
here I like it didn't also 31 didn't
souffle for the same age one she did so
he wanted back into Florida he wants
that tax break yeah probably yeah that's
true Tampa has got some great strip
clubs I've never been but I've heard
like when I was in college I went to
school in Florida this place called Mons
Venus was like the big I was like I
heard it was like one of the biggest
strip clubs in the country really so I
think it rivals Atlanta is like it's got
a lot of Miami
it's like Atlanta Miami Houston are the
best Holy Trinity of strip clubs
I got kicked out of the pink pony - pink
pony loans that Tony hey I own collagen
welcome how dare you get in a fight with
one of my [ __ ] you got in a fight
with a lady yeah yeah sure no I just she
started saying [ __ ] and then I stood up
and started getting yappy and then she
what were you guys arguing about because
I I'm not a strip club going guy I don't
give a [ __ ] and all my I was working on
my college roommates and they wanted to
go so I was just sitting there talking
to my friend kind of like in the
background they don't like what you
don't like when you go and you're not an
active participant yeah yeah that's what
she was bitching I've run into that
myself yeah she was not happy about that
you're just like not spending money like
you know hey man I'm serious we're going
to a like a argument with the stripper
in a in Montreal when I went to jfl a
few years ago uh-huh and we were arguing
over she was saying that uh I shouldn't
call myself an african-american because
you know I'm black and all this [ __ ] but
she was like a Jew Egyptian Jew and she
called herself Canadian like y'all were
slaves to and [ __ ] and how did this even
come up like we were just talking right
so we we've just gotten to this topless
yeah no look we were she was she was so
that's awesome I go with an emo
we were about race yeah she was pretty
much [ __ ] on a mayor being an
American like she was all
high-and-mighty right say a lot of those
especially in Montreal because of the
French influence there's like they don't
like him and I don't like I would order
a restaurant they would speak to me in
French for like weight loss like you're
like all right yeah I'm not I don't
speak French and they would keep going
okay and then so so after our little
spat we we were all leaving the strip
club like all the roast battle people
and I was telling them the story as we
were walking out yeah they're like which
one I'm like the one with the small
titties and then I turn around and she's
like out there with us and she heard you
yeah she was like smoking it smoking a
cigarette
she put a shirt on to [ __ ] come out
and have a cigarette yeah no she had it
she put a shirt on come on verse three
I'm like yeah they want the small
titties and she was just standing right
behind me she just was so hurt and I and
I felt bad about it she's like I'm gonna
get that I'm gonna get a boob job let's
show you I was at a UH
that something similar like that
happened me I was at a concert at Santa
Barbara Bowl and I was standing like
getting a beer for me and my sister who
was in our seats and then a song started
that I wanted to hear but I didn't want
to like be excuse me excuse me excuse me
going through the seats so there's all
these tables kind of like tabletops like
outside of the patio the store so I set
these two beers down kind of watching
from the side these two like cute girls
are standing next to me and Judd Apatow
just did a documentary on HBO about this
band The Avett Brothers and it just had
just come out and I said to these two
girls are you know a big fan of this
band they're like yeah I don't like to
see the documentary yet and she goes no
I haven't seen yet I'm gonna watch it
tomorrow I'm gonna go see the concert
first I go oh girl it'll knock your hits
off it's wonderful and her friends like
she just had a double mastectomy I was
like I am [ __ ] so sorry
yeah I swear to God I said you know how
is she feeling she was cooler her but
her friend was like [ __ ] real
defensive you know I mean but she was no
big deal how would you ever have known
I'm like I am that like few days earlier
[ __ ] where the odds of that say yeah
she's like coming out to get
yeah yeah you're gonna feel good and I
mind she runs into you know what I mean
it'll blow him back out similar story I
was doing La Jolla it was like me think
re was headlining um coach I was O'Neil
and then Pete Carboni Carboni and so we
go back to the condo or overlap we're
drinking and I think Carboni actually
invited these two chicks back always a
bad girl ladies come back O'Neil and Ari
get into a jujitsu off oh hey sports
band everybody's sports band
fashionably late it's still sit right
here while we get to [ __ ] set up our he
was wearing corduroy pants it's good
[ __ ] out of me by the way Ari's wearing
corduroy pants it was burning O'Neil
skin the the corduroy he's too late
opposite of a rash ladies were so
impressed that they left and Carboni was
incensed that they laugh were they cute
I forget but he was trying to hook up
with one of them and so he was like so
pissed like you guys to these women I
think Johnny has locked out Johnny's so
they're not so then the girls leave in
Carboni comes back and in an hour he's
like oh would you do with those [ __ ]
where are they with what they leave and
like they were saying all this [ __ ] no
Neil is talking I like [ __ ] about these
girls
and Carboni because we're all in the
master bedroom and Carboni goes they're
standing they got locked into the garage
and so they needed the key good time
here I'm gonna go take a piss all right
hey whatever red band welcome yeah nice
to see you I'm not late
Sports bad no you're right on time
actually you're perfectly on time it's
right what a minute early I assume I
don't get that t-shirt
you don't know Outback Steakhouse
outcast it's just a reality picture okay
I was like I didn't know they ever did a
promotional bag medicine you can exert a
lot of ridiculous mashups and sometimes
it's like that doesn't even make sense
um hand him yours and take that one oh
yeah baby you got it brother how's your
Tuesday going red band just woke up man
I was like so happy today cuz I just got
back from this tour we've been gone for
like eight days you've got to go back
out again aren't you in a couple of
weeks
oh but I was like oh Tuesday I have
nothing to do I'll just sleep all day
I'm so far behind in sleeping in and oh
yeah punch should I sign that contract
shouldn't sign that contract well tell
you what if you don't show up you're
gonna feel the wrath of one era Coligny
he was here all day yeah he was here
where uh where were you Redman where'd
you guys go we went to Idaho its Salt
Lake City Utah Boise Idaho Vancouver
Seattle Portland Northwest yeah like a
whole big chunk of white people how was
I that's it was pretty much white people
everything I know there's a lot of white
power
well of all of there is oh I love that
Idaho punch honor believes in you of all
of the places that you went what areas
had like the better kind of open mic
comics like what comics we're like wow
this surprising for Idaho 100% Portland
was just it makes it amazing
yeah me too they have a pretty decent
comedy scene music to like any place
that is like a lot of art and it was
cool awesome because we had the
guitarist from Portugal the man play
with the band in Portugal by the way to
our good friends Portugal the man I am
so sorry for your Portland Trailblazers
and their loss last night they had a
good run at a good season continue they
love them they love them what is that
baseball it's basketball but their
season just ended sports bag coming in
hot
but you know when you got that the
Jumbotron when you go to a playoff game
and then they're like they play some
song where they show the whole team and
all that they that they wrote and
performed the song for that Wow they're
huge fans they sit in the front row for
every game yeah yeah punch-drunk was
mentioned a few times though when we're
on the road oh they were like yeah I
love singing on punch-drunk oh nice well
that's cool thanks to everybody that
said that you gettin recognized in the
streets yeah they're like oh it's Sports
bad you know because if you hang out
with re like you know I've checking eyes
a lot icre is just like the idiot that
I've known for a long time people oh my
god you're sorry doesn't like it but
Christ loves it oh yeah you'll make like
a twenty Instagram videos about it I
don't Oh birds up yeah he's a fan
friendly guy yeah always like yep okay
yeah if you could touch me once but not
for longer than one second okay that's
it and you're standing there and you're
like do I keep talking to the bird
because I feel bad for like I don't know
I don't know I'm walking away too
no yep purpose all the time have you
been to Vancouver lately I've never been
never been Vancouver's crazy I don't
know if it's the area we stayed at but
it's like spring break at night like
just bars and bars and just trashed
people it was ridiculous really like we
were just trying to find a bar to like
chill at you know I just like have a
drink I like a dive bar yeah I want a
glass of wine possible like it was just
seeing had any street fights tons of
that tons of kidding yeah tons of like
we saw a lot of crazy [ __ ] like like
what like we saw a woman and a guy
fighting this was in a Kip see no no
this was a [ __ ] I can't even remember
the city yeah but we saw like I straight
up like a worldstar type like fight man
middle of a street like how the woman do
the woman was winning the guy was trying
to escape the woman was like straight up
throwing like like shoes at him and
stuff like that's nonsense she just had
a purse full of shoes I wonder what that
person Allah Nichols
I'm in the faith Sox for like two bars
of soap in a sock when I was in Denver I
saw street fight we were like let me run
as easy no Neil we were loving it and
then all of a sudden the cops came in
and just spraying a lot of mace it was
like going everywhere and we had to
really take cover from I was like just
trying to watch a cool fight here guys
the first Street Fighter I ever saw in
my life was also the first time I ever
went to a Chicago Cubs game scared the
living [ __ ] out of me because these two
dudes well they were big naturally big
guys they were just really going at it
like a huge circle of people around him
after the game but I'm also like seven
so they're even bigger in my head you
know do I really scare the [ __ ] out of
me like when like later on in the season
they're like hey let's go to the Cubs
game this weekend I'm like were they
were they furthest ain't were they
cheering for the Cubs or was it like cuz
they were just drunk guys in Chicago
fist fighting after the game who knows
what it was about maybe they were big
guys like in my head it was like to tape
those really it's a [ __ ] out of me those
are the best fights like when you go to
a sporting event and then it's like a
rival rivalry like we it's like I have
someone to cheer for you know you don't
know them but you know who you're
cheering for all of us went to the
Monday Night Football or Thursday Night
Football when it was like the Vikings
and Rams when all of us went there was a
[ __ ] good one of those in the stands
like right behind we're sitting oh yeah
yeah we yes crazy and some drunk there
was a there was a falcon at the Falcons
Rams game a couple years ago when we
beat them like 42 today yeah well I like
that much yeah there was a there's a
good fight in the fire there coach yeah
thank you I fired the next day yep
that's a gonna be any UFC event nowadays
yeah I wasn't dangerous people get all
[ __ ] revved up looking at I'm just
here to [ __ ] see that many fights at
UFC events that I've been to but I have
seen like video wise it seems like a lot
of Fighters that aren't on the card get
into fights like in the hallways and
[ __ ] you always see oh like yeah the
Diaz brothers are in town how excited
are you about them about the Diaz
brothers we'll see if it happens yeah
I'm gonna get on BET dsi see what the
odds aren't I might even have here
even fighting yeah it's it's always
there camp or Habib's camp is they all
[ __ ] love to fight yeah
they have those big white yep for hats
yeah yeah we were at the sycamore tavern
one night when he was fighting there
were like people in the crowd wearing
those [ __ ] things yeah that's right
at the last punch look one last time but
I think you got to be fearful what
country is he from it's not the Ukraine
it's another no but it's yet to wit
psyche you think it's Russia but it's
right never seen their president is
crazy yeah he loves MMA you like start
an organization but like any trains like
children absolutely it's crazy
it's from Dagestan it's part of Russia
but it's like its own little thing they
asked him he was unreal sports and they
like yeah that's why I thought there are
no gay people in this country wait what
yeah if you're gay he like [ __ ]
tortures you yeah but he's like there's
no gay people here it does not happen
and like if these gay guys speaking with
like with the voice distorter and then I
got fear for my [ __ ] life yeah
have you seen John Luke 3 no I haven't
seen it yet you yeah great but there's I
don't wanna ruin it have you guys all
seen the Avengers yeah I haven't seen
one of them I gave up on that Shimon
guys at the end parlour Iron Man does it
yet oh [ __ ]
just ruin somebody's life I hope [ __ ] it
I sure hope so
hi John when 3 is great it's [ __ ]
great I don't know they just keep
finding new ways to kill people yeah
it's amazing and when and the fourth one
comes out in two years
are you serious yeah do they T do they
tease it at the end or they have like ya
know okay John wick it's all right innit
did they do a preview for Bill and Ted's
yeah before so sad man I was talking
about this to some of the other day like
they haven't done a new Wayne's World
you know and I bet that's coming in how
sad that's gonna be with Mike Myers and
Tina Carter they don't like each other
they don't know not anymore
no I don't think they did then oh really
oh that's weird
you know she's got to have it Spike Lee
one of his first movie a TV show no oh
it's gonna be a show it's been a TV show
30 are aired it's on Netflix show years
it's a joint
oh yeah Mike we joined another season
like to do you remake um we did and then
okay I show mix it up how impressive is
the Camrys it's like 54 years old doing
all that [ __ ] it doesn't you know I've
seen the original script and the
original script a time like of John wick
called scorn okay and it and he was like
70 oh really
yeah I like that and in the original
that'd be cool
who would get to play him it was clear
by the cleanest wood cleanest wood or
like isn't Lea me some old Liam Neeson
we could pass for seven I think Liam
Neeson was like the original like who
was in mine they had in mindful he's
good at that kind of role yeah like in
the Takens and all those kind of things
he's like a god you're like oh man I I
like it I like Keanu in it though cuz he
I love it it's like it's a bit cheesy on
purpose and yeah that's what in such a
fun way
ya know yet it's it's the the
choreographed the choreography and it
does take got killed in the first one he
got [ __ ] it got killed every year did
shot him in the head you see Tate
Fletcher in the movie he's not gonna be
alive long he's like a black guy on Star
Trek man that killed pretty good in the
accountant I love ya he got with a belt
that's how you don't yeah yeah yeah
applicati
that was the scene with the 50 caliber
sniper right and he also got killed in
the last episode of Breaking Bad
Westworld well the season 3 trailer for
Wes that should look so [ __ ] good tap
down I don't even know I didn't even see
season two but I'm watching season two
it's very confusing
yes he's into ice died tapped out when I
was like I think I need a PhD to I know
what happens too much going on see the
one was fine season two of all over got
crazy Ben Affleck in the shitty season I
wonder if season 3 is like different
dude Ben Affleck should have fought in
the UFC if he's fighting a fighter who
was up with the head of those skills
Oh God in real life there's no way Kate
would murder
pasen furious he got like get beat up by
that what's-her-name who's that little
girl that's in that I'm Jordana Brewster
I don't know which or live or the
Michelle Rodriguez beat up by her and
then she throws him off this like LEDs
and then he gets hit by his propeller
there's the thought of her beating up
tape Fletcher is so hilarious to me as
the rock killed them yet is that like me
yeah that's escaped them it was like
Jumanji hiko he has keys in Jumanji
wasn't he like yeah he died in chiavari
he died in everything he just says pick
his ways of being killed by like all
these favors yeah Johnny Depp killed him
in the Lone Ranger shot him with an
arrow yeah that was a movie that I
killed I killed him in Red Dead
Redemption
Bill Cosby killed them in the late at
the third of The Cosby Show he went in
when he was an obstetrician he gets
killed John wet beard - or the John with
John wick one he can come back in
Westworld because they just record a
rebuild if we you know reboot him or
something yeah he could just be another
model when he I was saying to him I
think I said on this show look whenever
he'd like ninety five and he's got like
he's dying of natural causes when he's
in the [ __ ] hospital he's just gonna
grab the nurse would be like dummy out
the [ __ ] window
I've died in too many cool ways to go
out like this and that's the dude from
Breaking Bad right yeah yeah I hope I
hope it's like that motorcycle is just
that [ __ ] is dope yeah oh this is West
world yeah [ __ ] what is it an
autonomous motorcycle yeah that shit's
coming soon it's all I mean it's scary I
don't nobody likes Ronnie hey can you
take your new car and send it to go get
us some tacos well we have a pod right
now can your car suck your dick while
you drive a no question no no you can't
put it in the USB port just get it quick
have you jerked off in your car yeah no
have you [ __ ] in your car you know
uh-huh do you want what do you say
minutes is there anything you don't like
about it
yeah there's something that happened
last night that it's annoying and I
raped you I know this key fob I doesn't
have we're like any buttons
let me touch the side it opens the back
door you know and stuff like that but if
you wet put it in your pants and you
lean on it right like last night I came
out to the we got Thai food after the
comedy story two in the morning like in
Hollywood and I come out with my doors
just open man oh my god that's great I'm
glad no one stole anything like I bought
an Lanyrd this arm I start wearing it
over in your pocket while you're driving
can't you disable that I think you I
don't know I haven't figured out yet
that's another thing like there's so
much you can do in a car that it's
really like learning a new operating
system going oh there it is it's in
settings then go under and you know show
me but other than that not really too
much you know you get a range anxiety
which is like right I need to charge you
know like right now I have 60 miles left
and I'm like [ __ ] I got you know after
this I do for now oh it's full charge
like the best is there's a Burbank mall
down the street that has super chargers
and it takes like 45 minutes to go from
zero to 100 you know charging that's not
bad I'll go to a food court
don't you do you put it in like where it
only can cap out it like 95 person ought
to destroy them I see I think they're
cool but I just don't trust Tesla yeah I
don't like what happens if they go under
then then what
that's fixing your car yeah I mean
that's you know like any car you know
nowadays look at look at Ford like it
for just got rid of all their cars you
know like Ford Fusion and Ford still
around those yeah but parts for Ford
Fusion aren't gonna be around and laughs
yeah much longer but it's like that the
aftermarket before it is so like
expansive like there's gonna be it's
gonna be available right but like with
Tesla is such a niche like yeah the good
thing is is that there's not much to fix
you know in a Tesla like there's no
there's just two like engines that look
like little boxes that you pull out and
yeah you know the battery and I mean so
there's not many parts to it you know if
anything goes wrong it's it's not gonna
be too bad but I they're doing pretty
good I think I think they have wait you
got a Tesla you know it's also where it
helps to have someone like Elon Musk
who's committed to the vision of the
rather than just making money yeah I
think he would be willing to take losses
yeah well they talk about something
about any they doesn't know how to
bankruptcy but they need a billion
dollars to do it what's that I just read
something like something about Tesla
they need a billion dollars but there's
something about them the bankruptcy -
yeah may avert bankruptcy but it will
still need a billion dollars in cash
yeah billion in capital this is just an
analyst opinion I mean he'll do that no
problem I guess Tesla or you want what
I'll be like okay here's a zillion you
know yeah they're gonna be like selling
more flamethrowers yeah flamethrowers so
crazy they did who's uh who's lady oh
that chick yeah she's pretty who is it
really
she's nice battery yeah musician crimes
crimes yeah
oh that's the girl that was uh Leigh
Anne Grimes or grimy as her friend
sector caller Seth MacFarlane there yeah
looks like Boettiger you know he's an
Iron Man did you know the original Iron
Man you know yeah there's a part where
Llewellyn was speaking he Robert is
going through this party and like all
these rich guys and then he's like hey
Ilan when we gonna build a rocket or
something like that right there
that's cool yeah I had it's one of those
things that you know I've seen Iron Man
like five times I've never even noticed
yeah I think when I remem one came out
we didn't even know who he really was
yeah I think when that Roadster hits the
new one that comes out I think that at
Audi Audi electric car no no no the the
Tesla Tesla Roadster yeah I want anyone
that that thing comes out that's gonna
be pretty huge why what's so cool it's
so expensive well it goes it's two it's
two hundred thousand but it goes like
zero to 60 in like two seconds and then
it has a thousand-mile batteries yeah -
miles which is ridiculous can you live
in it look at it is that it for 200
grand you're gonna have to I think that
semi truck is gonna be a big part of
their future - semi truck is definitely
because I mean
imagine being happy I'd be terrifying
that one of them I know they're the West
what about the helices a helicopter
no not you'd be really worried when
you're running out of [ __ ] minutes up
and [ __ ] supposedly next I think he
said next year is when the Robo taxis
the thing supposedly starts and that's
good that's an interesting idea
imagine being able to like hey when I go
to bed instead of being an uber driver
I'll just tell my card to be an uber
driver and my car will do uber driving
while I'm sleeping and then good you
know pull back up in my driveway when
it's done and I'm making money while I'm
sleeping but then you're like who did
you kill last night yeah a big fence a
bunch of chicken feathers and it's just
corn and corn they come everywhere
people are just [ __ ] in your car yeah
yeah my cars turned into a gym hot tub
yeah blue is gonna have a black light
just get in your [ __ ] car
I like the Audi electric cars to the
ones as and the New Avengers yeah yeah I
died the one in the Avengers though was
a gas powered version of it for me
because it's not done in there so that's
Marcus Marcus Bradley yeah he's awesome
the steering wheel for this car is
amazing - it looks like kind of like
that like you're play Star Wars the old
video yeah where it's at got little
cynics like yeah yeah good night rider
that's something I want to get on my car
and I somebody told me you could buy
yeah look at that [ __ ] it looks amazing
somebody's told me you could buy the kit
light for you know to put you meet the
Tesla grill so when you're driving has a
little light going back probably on like
Hasselhoff's web so yeah guys go to
Tesla comm use the code D and O spell it
out da nd we got a Tesla deal you have a
referral code don't you yeah yeah you
get five thousand three miles
supercharger like when I bought mine I
used
Rinna's Easy's code and see if your code
out then maybe it's like a big number
I'll tweet it later today okay
but yeah it's so mean Rin is easy both
got like a thousand three miles and
right now it's five thousand three miles
which is cool so if anyone buys a Tesla
just using my link we both get free
mileage yeah look at that two hundred
grand once I take out my eye I hope I
don't know what color I'm gonna get so
much is grab two of them yeah it's a
good idea I hope they make them for like
cuz you know they're talking about
they're trying to force like uber and
them to make their all their cars like
electric cars so I hope they really the
best [ __ ] like uh-huh it cuz it'll help
Tesla out with money-wise here's my code
Brian
eight five four eight three that's not
that bad five four eight three I can see
why you said it's super long yeah
there's a code B security yeah you guys
got your live show coming up not too
high on the belly room the newly
renovated belly room they got rid of the
mirrors which is kinda weird didn't go
up there looks like another thing got
rid of the mirrors I heard it was a
convertible for a while oh yeah the roof
was off it was the [ __ ] the atrium
yeah did it rain I think it did what the
[ __ ] have you and it rained you just
dude you got to not get electrocuted and
it's just an alt show on the east side
yeah well I'm not worried about getting
electrocuted because according to triple
electricity doesn't exist cancer bro
every time you use [ __ ] iPods you're
dying
so what else is different about it is it
bit like did they add CGI I couldn't
tell I walked up there like sleeker okay
sprite I mean it's easier to film in
there does it feel smaller the mirrors
feels bigger
yeah felt bigger mirrors to make it very
hard to film but I did like the mirrors
because if you're at a packed show you
can have like a shitty seat and still
kind of see like a roast battle if
you're in the you know where the comics
sit at the roast battle yeah you're kind
of blocked you can't still see through
the mirror but yeah whatever one of the
details make it impossible to shoot one
of the
at all the spots were like like one
table that said Ari Shaffir got his dick
sucked here and yeah ha ha ha but
someone weird a turtle backpack and it
was I could tell you the name I know the
detail I know the name yeah she was
wearing a turtle back I think you could
have been up there at some point no but
she also blew Tony after that and then
blue Tripoli after that and then so
triplet found out he was third in like
four hours he was like oh damn it bro
that's always the guy I remember when I
worked there Adi like there was like a
back in the day when it was crazy they
had no cameras in there they were like
legit a long time legit gangbangs like
in the bathrooms yeah in a belly rub now
is in the main room I was out girls one
yeah it's like really big I got couch in
here it was a bigger lady on that couch
and I guess guys were just walking in
and she said to your see she's like very
cool he's like what are you doing in
here she's like dicks he's like well I
brought mine and he was in but then
there was a guy doorguy I won't say his
name but not a problem at the end of all
this like he was just making out with
his chick it's like everyone's like oh
no dude tell us who it is
I'll tell you after yeah yeah no I said
his name that no oh he said his name not
no-one but just our Luckies listen it JP
no in a mirror now there's a transgender
bathroom that that's just a perfect sex
place what it doesn't lock no I tried to
take a [ __ ] in there on Saturday which
one is the train when you walk up the
stairs I the transgene outta ya before
the men's room in the main user just be
a big room you walk on the red the red
door
yeah red door it's crazy that we have a
transgender bathroom but no elevator for
anyone to go
because I'm got if someone comes in in a
wheelchair I've won Sadek I had to carry
guys into the ORR you know those
wheelchairs way like a toilet I would
just tell them it's closed
sorry show's over sure that at five
thousand people here if you put English
a lot with a handicap placard legally
they have to park your car and I used to
hate oh great yeah I'm going in the
store I can park that I change that yeah
they change that a long time yeah that's
right that is no longer deemed Gelber
left they abolish that was a homophone
right overall dude your show is sold out
but what saw you're recording it right
are you shooting it are you just
recording audio what are you gonna do I
know that I think ATC is gonna gonna
livestream it oh great Weiss yeah so
tell them let's hear what it's all on
the plan I know we got a Earl Skakel
Yellin or Karen up cake the bush man
will be closing the show Wow yeah he's
gonna be live is he gonna be what's he
gonna do stand up we're trying to get
Bushman and fang Chow to do an
international comedy duo called chow and
chow in the bush so right now we're
trying to get Feng Chow into it he's
getting kind of crazies oh really
this is gonna be surprising to hear he's
kind of drunk the other night I'm
getting a little aggressive and sound
like to think so I know what's the will
say but yeah it's gonna be a good show I
want to see I don't have you guys been
falling wee man or Brad Williams but
they've been going at and I think we
man's been like talking [ __ ] talking
[ __ ] to Brad Williams I want to see that
roast I think that one hilarious to a
great guy
what's there just yeah guys a little
perm what I need from what I understand
women has been just attacking pride
Willie man's living out of a like a
pimped out yeah it's pretty badass car I
think it was [ __ ] that he imeem
[ __ ] with a P but [ __ ] that he
put his license plate out there you know
like we made that video yeah he's living
in it he's living in his car yeah he's
living no but it's a pimp like pimp my
ride kind of RV but dude a van to hit
like a condo to us yeah no he sleeps on
like a seat but it's like for me it
would be horrible but for him it's like
a huge bed yeah yeah yeah it's like a
queen-size bed yeah he's like this is
great and it's like for me when you
bought the car he goes how many square
inches is this house you if you're a
little person does your luggage is your
luggage would be a little also like you
haryana be like when your clothes
what if Dinklage just comes in over the
top yeah who do you all are good eater
Dinklage Brad Williams are we man we met
looks a little taller than Brad Williams
there but he's had his head back so it's
hard to tell Dinklage is 44 yeah you're
not as short as I thought he would
that's Dinklage if you walked under
Lucas [ __ ] Oh Brad Williams is the
exact same height if your lady was
[ __ ] Dinklage you're like hey man
it's he's Dinklage has got people also
search for @oh we men's the smallest how
short for flat oh I was - eight - eight
G boy but he said in a scooter so he was
taller than all of them he knows 510 if
anyone know Brad Williams is only 35
he's a young wait wait wee man is is
Latino I didn't know that either Cunha
or Hawaiian Hakuna Matata Hakuna Matata
my owns the taco shop I guess yeah
that's right middle name Shannon so is
he a good taco shop yeah
so he's born in Italy Wow
this is a lot of women and for all your
wee man news guys go to wee man calm use
the code Brian eight for one then I get
your free taco as wee man never been to
the comedy store seems easy a guy who'd
come it comes to kill Tony almost that's
why and they have to jerk you off or
finger your [ __ ] either which way I'm
[ __ ] in any Ari Shaffir updates
from anybody anybody talk to me he say
he's gonna come on next week all next
week to talk about the pelicans getting
high on he's gonna be in town couple
soon I know that what's he coming to
town for I think he's got some stuff
going on he's camping I don't know but
then he's leaving he's going out of the
country soon too though so I don't know
how about this what's that oh yeah you
know Tuesday did the [ __ ] walk paid
off if anybody doesn't follow Pancho
uh-oh so you had to be a transgender all
day or just for an hour
thank you where did you go I had to walk
from Sycamore tavern to the store and
create a ruckus along the way yeah we
filmed it we got a lot of goods you make
any money
no it's so he did offer me McDonald's
what the [ __ ]
no they just go hey man you want some
McDonald are their night he said you
want a happy meal yeah a happy meal
that's what he said that's code yeah
anal well I said like code I said yes
and then he [ __ ] his [ __ ] on yeah
probably that's the classic trick yeah
yeah by the way anybody want a happy
meal
they'd Sam Tripoli have to do it didn't
he have to do something awesome no no
fun okay so we had been walking we ended
up deciding that he would just walk from
Sycamore tavern in the Comedy Store and
drag originally he was gonna let linger
and the [ __ ] name what kind of shoes
that was the only thing Chuck Taylors no
heels exes I would have died in here I
gave him a walk good in [ __ ] Chuck
tail we've been walking like five
minutes and Sam was following us in the
car the whole
way across the street we could see him
and he got his phone he calls me in the
middle of it he goes and we're walking
you know there's nobody around so we're
walking at a pretty good pace he goes
what are you guys doing
and I said we're walking he goes yeah
and he sounds so disappointing goes
power-walking stop Nate you were walking
fast well we were coming I came up with
about seven different funny gags that we
did when I went in that liquor store and
by the way I didn't just when I went in
that liquor store I go can I get a pack
of Marlboro Lights and you know those
little shots of Jack Dana's we're gonna
have shots on me drinking out while I
was pissing like holding my dress up and
[ __ ] and he goes free you want that to
go so like seven-year-old arab guy how
did it feel this is new I've never yeah
I definitely would do it again and
actually did do it again should go to
LaBrie in Santa Monica that's where it
like that's where you're gonna do that
all the [ __ ] is there's a reason Boone's
your mentor this is odd this is you're
in life trajectory I have learned from
the best
yeah you and Willy hunter should go out
for a night have you seen Willie he ever
since that that filter that snapchat
filter that makes you like a woman he's
been toasting like three of those a day
last night at the historical was
premiere you wore a dress that lasts
straight-up dress not really makes a
good girl Jilly Hunter [ __ ] she's high
look at Jilly smiled like this try to
find a dress I think it was posted on
Jeremiah was it yet Jeremiah's in last
night Jeremiah caught him out
that's funny oh I did the chair my
wonders podcast if anyone's away that
was pretty fun yeah you were really good
yeah thanks everybody's had some good
things to say about it it's only one
other kind of stories that's I know that
yeah interesting
you were funny in that in that episode
of Jeremiah yeah we liked every
impression from the Comedy Store I did
that I that can I can do in school it's
really fun Tony Theo yeah Don yeah do
you do
Willy Hunter I did Willy hunter when I
gave him a happy meal the other day if
you know what I'm saying what kind of
dress was did he have on who is he it
was like a green yeah and it look good
was he showing titties it was it was
like it was like titties some people
were dressed up for like in his and
historical clothing and he was just
wearing like oh yeah I give squatty
potty's to a lot of people really yeah I
just yeah I gave him an address right
it's coming yeah she's wearing a boxing
robe he's like a mustache Wow
yeah he's been touched that is uh I get
it it was the freest pee I've ever had
in my life I pissed twice in the dress
and I was like this is very easy to do
seems like you would go to the kilt
before just the full-on dress yeah thank
you snap chopped Corp it made it very
easy to finger me yeah yeah it's easy
access uh Isis are a hundred easy where
on his panties no no undies my prison
purse I'm not [ __ ] right to my [ __ ]
gee I wish I had a purse I should have a
purse for Oman would you do that wig Sam
was really concerned about getting that
wig back put it in his car later he was
like I can't believe do you okay
he's the one who was like let's go to
the store and humiliate you
he wouldn't the the dress and flossing
he got the dress at Ross for $8.00 he
wouldn't let Tebow take the text you
want to return it yeah like there's [ __ ]
stains all I'll give you eight dollars
it's a happy meal but then so we go
there and it's like everybody's having
goofs and making the house and all this
sort of [ __ ] and I was sitting in the
back and Boone was in the back when John
was I should have had that Warner back
so I was uh what it was a vanilla
Shakalaka whatever it was so whatever he
would say I would just mimic it but it
was like a new dude bro I got now I'm
leaning into this problem wearing this
thing all night cuz he wanted to leave
right when the bet was over why couldn't
you give him the wig like a week like
give it to in the next day but why did
he need it right that second because
morning yeah you wanted never what use
it again he got it from the hustler
store that pink one yeah yeah kill tony
has a bunch you could buy him like that
wish calm that website the or dollar you
know you could buy like a hundred of
them for it all crazy wigs has anyone
see the act on Hulu yeah I've seen watch
it's Oh about the key the bald kids in
the picture and the mom so it's about
this mom who's doing Munchausen by via
proxy in the die so it's based on a real
story it's crazy it's what's-her-name
Arquette
but your turn I love her as the mom and
she's unreal he's a great actor it's his
[ __ ] this the girl like she shaves
the daughter's head cuz she tells her
she has leukemia for like her whole life
I remember he tells like partially
paralyzed the girls in a wheelchair
there's like a 20 20 years Dateline or
something about yeah there is yeah dude
it's crazy the show is [ __ ] great so
weird cuz she tries to be like like
there's a moment when she's trying to
like a sexually gets into sex and it's
so weird because her yeah voice is like
this she's like repeat she looks like
steps and barri
I said the same thing dude her face is a
lot like yeah alright I think that okay
I was like why does she look so goddamn
father she got beat out by this girl
Joey King yes a great Joe if anyone
wants to yes very I'm absolutely gonna
watch this what did you think was better
this or escape from Dannemora I didn't
see that I heard I liked Dannemora
she was in that too right she was the
lady was [ __ ] the imprisonment so how
old is the daughter the daughter or
timeline she doesn't know her age cuz
the mom doesn't she like lies to her
about her age to keep her younger so
what did she tell her she is she's like
four years off the girls like online
behind the mom's back like trying to
meet dudes to like [ __ ] and she in real
life she went that she would go to like
these comic con type events in Missouri
wherever the [ __ ] they're from and she
would she [ __ ] this guy in the
bathroom the moms like waiting yeah
she's like who seems like a prisoner
yeah life and so she was China
she's always Balkan she has the mom
shaves her head she kills her she finds
a guy online who kills the mom or that
guy got [ __ ] railroad you got a life
in prison she only got 10 years and she
manipulated him into doing it he was
like his parents were like he's autistic
and he has [ __ ] like personality like
never a real right guy that really does
look like somebody no no down go down
that's her right there oh yeah that's
the real one yeah yeah that's her right
there
yeah okay they kind of they kind of do
look a lot yeah it's [ __ ] it's a
crazy story that video she jumps off her
railing and in like I'm like dude they
claim she I couldn't walk like what the
[ __ ] is this hot [ __ ] her she had so
many surgeries all these doctors were
just giving her surgeries that she
didn't anything yeah it's crazy the mom
would just tell him like we lost of
records in Hurricane Katrina she said
the mothers just a full-on whacking yeah
nutjob not oh she a path then how they
got a week when they were getting like
yeah that's why I saw 20/20 they were
getting like make-a-wish money they were
getting all these donations like the mom
was just like hustling right right but
then the girl got like too old and
like hey man I'm liking my twenties I
don't want to be I mean I would
definitely [ __ ] that kid if it was
wearing willies well you just lost us
gosh as a sponsor yeah use the code Dino
101 get free from behind did the toys a
roster dating profile if she was on like
Christian dating for free or strike one
I'm no model I have a medical condition
so I can't walk I have a chair I use
well that's not already I'm hard is that
an issue that's not true though why
would that be a problem you're an angel
in my eyes this guy the guys dude the
guy he is like a person he claims one of
his personalities as a vampire yeah and
he's like that's believable it's yeah
it's a crazy story Wow Gypsy Rose I'm
gonna watch the little [ __ ] out of that
today it's enjoyable and then you watch
the HBO documentary about it because
they interview the real girl in prison
oh that's what I saw because I ate via
doc I think how long does she get ten
years yeah she's still a she's still in
the kid but she'll get out at yesterday
straight is she said she's like it's
like you'd be a great mom you have a
great role model yeah like why not have
a bunch of yeah she knows that she
dropped that a gun with Maggie Mia
second grade cuz her mom just took her
out of school she's like where's the mom
now dad they killed how did they kill
her the dude stabbed her like a million
times
oh yeah then they [ __ ] directly after
stabbing her in the in the house so
that's her with her yeah she grew it out
she looks like my ex-fiance oh [ __ ] is
maybe it is she would have stabbed here
was your ex-fiance an 18 year old that
was bald I know
did you talk like this
and our teeth fall dude no they they
like wool in the show she just the mom
claims she was allergic to sugar and
she'd started to eat like would sneak
like coke and [ __ ] and her teeth like
all like they had to like pull them all
out Wow yeah they really have to pull
him out her she was a sadistic I'm not
sure the woman yeah I don't know about
that to be honest this guy's great dude
the boyfriend is a [ __ ] yeah like a
fishing knife she goes to like an REI
type store by the way REI today have
their annual sale if you're into I know
it's like it's like use the promo code
rude idiot take up to 50% off a lot of
their [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah I guess stuff there
for my balls I'm big into hiking now I
hit up alright the other day and he's
like oh mom in Nebraska I'm hiking so I
was like what like a flat [ __ ] tube
right wait what do you pray that you
mean you're walking in the woods
I'm in a cornfield yeah I walk about
soybeans yeah yeah just like [ __ ]
shredder that's uh it's a tough acting
role because they're like the good news
is is you're getting this huge shield
bad news we're shaving that hand extra
money though and I can't you get number
11 from [ __ ] street you get some of
them they actually has leukemia yeah
that would be nice to help out like a
real yeah they like people play an
Indian yeah a bit Indian actor it's a
good point it's a very good boy
well you if you should only hire
leukemia actresses I don't know how many
there are but gobby at least one and do
the problem isn't ooh can't we talk to
your doctors yeah yeah we're planning a
three season arc so how bad is it but
she wears wigs when she like they have
like phone sex with that guy and she
wears these crazy wigs that's what maybe
when you brought up all the wigs and
it's it's actually good are you saying
no it's good it is kind of funny but it
is good like just our cats like
nominated for like every award for it
okay she's a great actor
so great she's great she was great
neighborhood she was hot as hell in true
romance oh yeah so medium remember
there's a medium she was hot now she was
she was she fought Tony Soprano like 12
rounds oh yeah down the down the street
at the hotel that Hotel it Becky father
was in Burbank yeah it's okay my
girlfriend usually it was like a
celebrity boxing match no in the movie
there's a true romance no no this is the
first one that he wrote the first one
that Quintin you would love to true all
that right there is a classic yeah right
in there yeah this is everybody Brad
Pitt rap a young Rappaport yeah Tony
Soprano is one of the best sound ever
alkie from perfect Smile yeah the
cocaine part oh my god have you Balki
Sean Penn's brother walk it walkers for
walking dude walking that is part of me
that's peaches yes it's okay that scene
is insane Oh Gary Oldham yeah I know I
love Tarantino stuff it's absolute class
it's one of my favorites I think if not
my favorite Tarantino I think Taran
better than Kill Bill very close very I
think Tarantino had beef with it I liked
it but I didn't like I know he didn't
like what the director did would it I
think the writing partner allege is that
Tarantino ripped a lot of his [ __ ] I
think this was one of them I could be
wrong on that though yeah this was kind
of kind of those weird Tarantino movies
kind of like a Natural Born Killers
where it came out and like is Tarantino
backing this movie or not yeah he's like
pretty flawless yeah
which crazies I saw this movie at the
Hollywood Cemetery where they play the
movies matter you know where I was
sitting I was right next to the director
that tie oh really
Wow and you were just talking Tony Scott
you're just talking [ __ ] about the movie
the whole time I'm like I'm really weird
add a guy that made this his body's
buried right next
I was uh I was there I forget what I was
well I think I was watching Caddyshack
there and I was drinking some beers and
I was like I got a piss and the line was
super long so they just have like those
[ __ ] outhouses porta-potties so I was
like so I was like looking around I was
I'm just gonna piss right here but that
was like a tomb still like very close to
where I think I was like but I was like
what oh my god and there's nowhere to go
right I have to I mean you're already
watching a movie yeah I go there piss on
graves when there's no movie trailer in
the middle of the day
has anyone been to that venue there's a
venue where yeah Duncan Chelsea's dad
chose that name Joe DeRosa filmed this
specially at this image yeah it's really
it's like pretty cool it's like a church
okay almost yeah it looks like it's like
a big cool church on the inside Duncan
Trussell is my brother
everyone accuses me of being really and
I'm actually have you seen him because
we're a little different different
heights and different statures I told
him when I last saw him and he's like
yeah there it is
and he's like oh my god he's like you're
like me if I was healthy and then he
asked me to if people ask you that he's
like did you show him your balls it's a
good thing I should do though a black
dude at Mitzi's Memorial came up to me
and he's like a guy I was like I think I
recognize this guy from him being here
back in the day music man look at look
at that guy it was Ari I was like yeah
he's like he looks like [ __ ] man what
happen to his hair I was like older I
don't know everyone looks like [ __ ] man
I look the same he's like I barely
recognize you and I was like he's like
you look a lot different man and I was
like I don't know if I know you look
like Duncan now and is like I'm not done
there's a good reason for that yeah hey
he just looked at me he's like what and
I was like I'm not Duncan he's like oh
man he walked away because he's like
that same guy came up to me and thought
I was Marsha Warfield really yeah yeah
so funny he said I did a show with her
in Vegas I just saw her at the store
recently really why I thought of her
name she's alive as you live in Vegas in
LA she was walking around
ra's with a friend she's like six eight
isn't she she's like the original Leslie
Jones not tall she's not
and I taller than me that's on me she
was tall though disappointing she was
tall but not toward me
what do you tell me that but yeah yeah
yeah but yeah she was just walking
around showing her friend like all the
names on the wall and stuff didn't even
go in to watch the show she was there
for like 10 minutes yeah I stopped to
talk to him for a bit did she find her
name she thought yeah over yeah she was
like oh yeah I can't believe you
recognized me you're still young I'm
like I'm 7 I got ya I'm 85 I love Corey
beard well my mom told me I was 8 is
boss still alive from that court I would
say no but I don't know I'm gonna vote
that's all gasp I'm gonna go say yes yes
I'm gonna say yes even though he's
taller and a richard mole is what's his
name I think is Richard Moll
Harry Anderson died all right pity yeah
here is his dead vice principal my high
school looked exactly like Harry
Anderson died last year he was a regular
at the store I love this Richard most
still alive yeah he does he didn't even
look look look at him he doesn't even
look like him yeah it's like Kenny
Rogers now she kind of does he looks
like a Brody lived to be 70 still look
like Brody yeah oh wow he does that's
crazy
what was that a comedy a come on it was
during the The Cosby Thursday night at
1:00 yeah it was one of the bigger
bigger sitcoms like cheers and whatnot
old Larroquette John Larroquette Brendan
Fraser's mate
I was with Larroquette come on Oh stay
with me stay with me any thoughts of
that basketball game last night
great tough wafer I know you're a
glorious fan nation and I don't see it
was good I don't see any way any team
can win a game in and what's the other
series at it's 2-1 Milwaukee - under
walkie I think Milwaukee wins out the
honest look like [ __ ] in Toronto yeah he
did I think Drake may have done some
sort of [ __ ] some Canadian food is
his problem man do Drake shows like a
team every like he shows up at Kentucky
despite being from Canada like he's like
the ultimate
Toronto guy the ultimate Ari Shaffir he
was yeah he was owning the cursor
wearing giannis Jersey under his [ __ ] I
doesn't just like send tons of hookers
Wow yeah yeah yeah or lactose and in his
eyes like that old ninja my mr. Fuji
yeah I hope this goes the game seven in
time and ever it's every game is over
Kyle being Clippers read the Clippers
next year bro all kinds of trades last
night Lonzo ball's gonna end up on the
suns and Anthony Davis is gonna be I
think it also on this [ __ ] now if I was
Anthony Davis I'd consider sticking
around I think they'll be now do you
guys on it's just harder to that market
I think we want to live down a new mix
are gonna take I understand that to
Knicks are gonna take our Jay Barrett
they're gonna Trey his teammate they're
gonna trade him for Davis so they'll
play together I could see that do you
think they'll plating actually that I
can see that that's a good a good call
and I think somebody maybe they couldn't
win the damn neon can Challa champion I
can't shoot
RJ bears are worse three-point shooter
in Zion sometimes that is terrible 99%
pull up Zion so it's 30 percent for a
guy maybe like before in shooter he's at
19 in five getting bad he may be like
hundred like couldn't hit a [ __ ] yeah
he could get fat if he's not careful
yeah he does have that Shaq kind of like
he's big he's dude he's like 275 and
he's 19 he's a big [ __ ] he did
play football he's in the LeBron it'd be
a good time edited or or D or [ __ ] uh
I think I mean tied in obviously but I
think he'd be a good linebacker crazy
that imagines trying to imagine trying
to throw a slant over how old is he look
60 like LeBron really gene
dude he looks old you said his prom in
year ago oh that was this done Barris
ask that tongue
he says tongue scraper yeah you know how
he got recruited as he was playing
pickup and they were looking at another
guy playing like a real game and they
said like who the [ __ ] that guy would
I point pick up and
him really and no one recruited them
that's I mean it up Amari State Wow I
like that taco guy what's his name taco
falls like 18 feet tall kid good thing
is like he's a freak yeah it's just a
freak yeah I'm excited what do you think
he's gonna go to you think two or three
you think the worries getting me any I
love I love him on the polls
I think the Bulls might get Kobe white
by the way that's the latest mock drafts
I've seen guy have them taken him you
see white at point guard no you look bad
god damn I mean that's incredible
where is Marty state said one of those
ones that's in Indiana no Murray State's
not Indiana goddamn positive that but
it's uh like [ __ ] isn't Bill Murray
like the founder yeah Bill Murray is
guitar lucky yeah he's like I didn't say
like Lexington or someplace like that
president Bill Maher II okay that Hank
tyrant goddamn holy [ __ ] isn't Bill
Murray in a new zombie movie is that
real oh yeah zombie movie what's dead
with Adam driver what's dead [ __ ] cat
it's like they're in the air what the
dead don't die there you he seems like
said you got to seen that documentary
about him Bill Maher ya know what's
wrong it's on Netflix and it's just all
this story everybody tells all these
stories about he's a weird dude how he
just shows you know cell phone no yeah
he has no he's a Colin yeah Charleston
South Carolina most of the year he owns
like a restaurant there he loves to just
go in bartender random bar the whole
mood documentaries about that it's all
this joy weird thing he he went to a
college what going by this college party
recognizes college party was all girls
having a college party just walks in is
he boning and no and everybody's like
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] Bill Murray and he's
in the kitchen having a beer and talking
one of the girls that lives there and
it's like once you guys do your dishes
please look sloppy you gotta have your
dishes done and like I'll do tomorrow
party and he's like I'll do him puts an
apron on does all their dishes and then
just leaves he does [ __ ] like that all
the time in the whole documentary is
everyone telling these stories about it
and I knew this dude he in he
you a guy he wasn't eating at a
restaurant and bill Mari like walked he
was walking by to the table and I think
Bill Murray like he like grabbed the guy
I did something weird anything no one
will ever believe that's that's the name
of a doctor documentary and it was one
guy at a bar that was peeing and he
grabs people's him he'd become folsom
and whispers no one will ever believe
you and a guy turned around it was Bill
Murray when we went on Netflix how old
is this two years maybe you can get away
with it like my fingers in your ass no
one's gonna believe these things then it
makes it so he could do bad things yeah
no one's gonna believe yeah yeah people
people in South Carolina were taking
their wedding photos
I remember that one and then he stormed
in and saw their wedding photos are like
these two people in Bill Murray and they
had a threesome with them yeah and he'd
[ __ ] them shut yeah I think yeah plays a
kickball game a random kickball game the
event got a divorce then he just went to
Europe without telling his wife for like
a long time that's hilarious
like where is he and he's like duh that
one's funny the kickball one because he
shows up and in his random Park and just
with a hat on like that and wants to
play kickball and these [ __ ] canta
like you can't be in a game given to me
this is just a private game and then
they realizes Bill Murray and then now
they love it and I'm like you know he
supports shitty little single a minor
league team and Charleston too and does
all their promo videos and stomach that
like selling season tickets shows up at
this party and starts playing with the
band just a random holy [ __ ] yeah like a
festival some sort of maybe Austin Music
Festival is something shows up playing
tambourine they run out of beer and they
and guys like Bill Murray was like I'll
pay for the beer just I'll give you
money just go get more beer and like no
no your money's no good here and Bill
Murray's said pulled out like a snowball
at cash and he goes no it's cool I've
been saving
all the people there at that party and
then a cop show up to bust the party cuz
they're playing music so loud and they
are ready
Bill Murray comes up just like playing
the tambourine you like shake it in
their face I heard cops like Bill Murray
yeah it's cool guys I already killed one
of the cops he's like no one will
believe this yes they had a flat tire in
that one he had a flat tire and somebody
random he pulls up like is that [ __ ]
Bill Murray he's like hey my name is
Bill Terry what if it's the ultimate
prank that it's just a guy who it's a
look-alike and sound-alike that'd be
funny
he's at a Comic Con he's at a Comic Con
and somebody in the audience asks him if
all these stories are true about all
this and he has like these glasses on
and he goes I don't think they're true
and winks I love that maybe lost in
translation it's all relaunch that a
million times
I've never seen great suppose I've never
seen a great opening shot of Scarlett
Johansson's ass she's so hot in that so
hot in that hotter than Bill Murray not
hotter than Bill Murray bum hot let's
not get crazy
Oh guys it's one o'clock oh thank you to
all of our sponsors think all of you
guys for showing up today I do you think
I'm gonna plug ya got coming you're
gonna buy a Tesla use the promo code
Danish five nine for every every mile
you get AI get $10,000 and you get
twenty thousand that's pretty sweet
Danish no Neil on iTunes absolutely one
of my favorite podcasts I've listened to
every single episode and don't forget
June 20th
all things companies gonna livestream
your 200th episode check it out so check
it out what about you [ __ ] next
Monday you can catch me on a historical
roast Netflix okay yeah Frederick
Douglass
oh nice check out the patreon for an
Ewok coming up oh yeah that's gonna be
on our patreon so if you wanna see the
training walk
I got a promise you there's a lot of
really funny gags in it it's not just me
walking down the street with Tripoli
yelling how much for a [ __ ]
[Music]
Koh Tony's about to go back on tour
we're gonna be many orc all right
although all the East Coast places
Oakland
bunch of [ __ ] go desk Squad TV and click
on tour dates there you go I'll be at
the Comedy Store or Wednesday Thursday
and Monday so come see me there and
consider it sucked consider it